truly I haven't even checked in with you
during this whole crisis how are you
doing I'm just sitting here quietly in
the kitchen of my partner hoping my kids
don't ruin this segment what what do you
know about Eric do you want to give us a
quick update his apartment is filled
with junk food he has about 40 bottles
of soda stocked up
he's got cupcakes he just ordered a
mixed drink making machine for his dog
because his bar he's got about five yeah
he has a bar set up where it's got a
machine like a coffee machine but it
makes mixed drinks very good listen you
know what Julie saying is there no
concern especially during coronavirus
when you have to keep your immune system
up cupcakes soda all of the mixed drinks
I mean again your your you know if you
get coronavirus you're not gonna survive
at your weight you have a compromised
immune system yes surely our he asked me
last week if I want him to come over and
help with the kids like I don't think he
gets teaming at all like I'm even
looking at Julie's setup what's behind
it's very nice all the kids pictures
yeah I got I got some family photos up
behind me the place is trashed the kids
are just running us just ragged it's
hard man it's hard because the 20 dates
neither dogs the plague that's a dog I
thought that was you kid I think Wow
Shirley's cases they got an interesting
look that's your dog